he's been called the most influential
person in football
nasserole khalifi is qatar's power
behind Global Sports Investments
during the World Cup he's hosting Sports
and Business Leaders and viewing attacks
on the tournament from Europe as
unwarranted politicians they want to use
the sport to promote themselves
to do to achieve something in their
agenda they will not success definitely
you know because
Sports is sports nothing to do with
politics and that's what we're doing
here in Catholic just Sport and football
so all the politicians try to use this
for their own agenda all of them failed
but the Qatar sport is also a means of
projecting power isn't it we have to be
proud to do and say it loudly that we
are proud of our country and we've been
done
for the World Cup and before the World
Cup Mr khalifi has gained prominence
running Paris Saint-Germain with
spending power attracting Talent like
Neymar
ahead of England's World Cup clash with
France teenager Jude Bellingham is on
his radar
amazing player water player honestly
England lucky to have him to be also
known he's one of the best player on the
under in the tournament and amazing I'm
just here I was you know first World Cup
and calm and relax and you know I'm in
Comfort them amazing are you onto your
recruitment team saying how can we sign
Jew Bellingham listen everybody I'm not
gonna hide it you know but I mean I
respect he's in his club and respect for
if we want to talk to him we'll talk to
her first
in club football Mr khalifi has a big
say over the future of the champions
league as if you wait for power broker
he backed protest that torted a super
league but the Breakaway threat remains
you've still got Barcelona and Real
Madrid pursuing this Super League you
know management what they want honestly
I mean no they're playing Champions
League so why are they playing
Championship they don't want if they
really criticize in terms League let's
leave Champions League go play by
yourself plenty of the master go do a
super cup between three of you what are
you playing the championship if I don't
like something I say I don't like it and
I'm not gonna do it you think you've
definitely killed off the Super League
it's gone
he's trying to keep European football
United and grow Qatar sporting status
Rob Harris Sky News Doha